[Musique]
il
et
je
[Musique]
moi
et
m
ce soir
[Musique]
votez
mais que mme harel
[Musique]
à gauche
d'ici là
attention
m
[Musique]
je suis
avant
- chelsea
[Musique]
et
mais que moi
oui
[Musique]
ayew
mais sexuellement comment ça va mais tu
vois quand elle nous raconte sa voix il
peut t'arriver ces trucs terribles
[Musique]
exister cela dit on peut bien sûr que
l'ancien matin c'est un endroit drague
ouais c'est là le soir il se demande
sans arrêt complet ici c'est plus calme
à mais ici c'est un sac à main ou bien
que nous était pour elle
[Musique]
il est
un peu vite fait bien peu aller voir
s'ils croient pas ce qu'ils voient le
vrai dell vient donner corps à terre la
rentrée soit besoin tombe bien
c'est le vrai deuil vous le connaissez
hollande aussi un cadeau si tu comprends
tout ce qu'on dit absolument oui ils
sont en train de te dire c'est une
énorme star alors oui si j'attends ton
nouveau disque avec un patient
exactement 1 35 35 ans que je le connais
depuis 35 ans à l'époque je suis becker
c'est ça si tu étais adopté d'ailleurs
par joséphine les besoins des enfants
des dribbles à vous
vous êtes là pour longtemps m'a réussi
deux semaines de cela veut seulement
deux semaines
né comme ça sur tous les canaux
le cno de français dans dix jours on
retourne en lan vous êtes en vacances où
vous vivez comme ça tout le temps non
c'est la vie c'est votre ville et ses
marines
vous voulez
mais ce qui nous arrive vous avez
inventé à vous avez inventé un brevet
qui vous rapporte de l'argent toute
votre vie
j'ai fait de petites entreprises
affichent une forme d'une entreprise ne
connaît pas la crise
bah oui c'est bien vous avez vendu après
vous avez dit c'est un bateau je vais
partir
l'odeur bientôt la demande
après quatre semaines rémy qui retourne
en france pour la méditerranée
ouais moi disons pas quatre mois à bord
de la mer mais c'est exactement ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui mais c'est bien non
c'est très bien et vous transporter de
la drogue n'ont personne juste on lire
sur des panneaux en occitan ont fait
parce que sinon ce serait bien
des types et des noms j'en vois pas où
on allait
oui enfin on va voir ce qu'on va voir
son copain d'entraînement se voir cette
production voir comment on dit au revoir
au long des seuils au nar anon czeslaw
et dare dare dare dare you need is as
raconte ce serait con là tu leur dis
quoi tu leur dis des conneries
aujourd'hui j'ai pris son cours les
français je peux dire ce que je veux les
enfants ouais c'est très bien c'est très
bien c'est pour ça qu'on t'aime
enfin m persie sur ses partisans ils
sont sympas ces gens-là et hollandais
finalement parce qu'il valait mieux pas
entendu je te confirme ou non mais
plutôt des hollandais par foot anglais
allemand français et on les sentiments
néerlandais inverse des français sont
assez typiquement européens comme
mélange de contredire ils sont bluffés
quelque part et en même temps il coupe
de france rennes nombriliste et
prétentieux mais les français ils sont
prêts à tout pour avoir l'air chic
intelligent fonctionne mais en même
temps l'étranger est quand même bluffé
ouais il est un mélange de
jalousie et de mépris pour les français
alors on land quand ils m'ont demandé
pourquoi tu te sens bien en force il y
mêlant de vous me trouviez arrogant et
enfants s'ils passent inaperçus
[Musique]
je n'ai pas changé je faisais de la
danse ils ont la sympathie connaissais
pas non c'est quoi ça sébastien luthier
français ouais c'est un chef j'ai assez
sens chez moi j'ai exactement ça moi
aussi
la coulée à offrir le mien initiale
comme en défense il parle toujours des
chalutiers journal télévisé ça ne l'est
jamais vu ah bon c'est ça on est devant
soir concernant les concerts à grand
tapage vous pas qu'à madame abattu mais
c'est une horreur insupportable un
supporter quelque chose de très grave
ça dépasse 100 mètres carrés mais enfin
bon gars là c'est d'ailleurs extérieur
dans sa galerie bernabeu c'est pas mal
quand même vachement bien faire nos
bases
ouais en fait des voeux vous interpréter
quelques chansons des beatles ah oui à
boxer 2 mais je me sens très généreux
avec lui bon soir tu allais bonsoir voir
ses projets que vous n'êtes que news en
écriture voilà on a cessé son se connaît
depuis
non c'était quand il ya quinze ans ça
fait que de 70
imagine 7,17 on était jeune elle était
beau il ya encore bon et là vous êtes
connus ou dans une boîte un peu on s'est
connu un set je connais pas cette visite
est de quoi tu sais pas moi j'allais
là-bas parce qu'il y avait une très
belle femme ouais c'est moi c'était les
sites et d'endroits où il ya les rémois
et il y avait aussi bien sur des films
et vous êtes le premier soir sa femme
cette histoire pour un bon ballon à oui
tiens bonne idée bonne idée
allez je sois je vais me faire aux
bateaux finalement c'est incroyable
parce que le nom de qui vient de me voir
finalement ils se disent bon allez c'est
pas mal de bateaux parce que alors
encore las il fait un peu frais mais dès
que les beaux jours arrivent c'est fait
campagne à ses fins et tous les soirs
tout le monde se connaisse le village à
paris imaginez mon bateau en bas des
tours d'argent ouais dire que légèrement
mais en octobre
[Musique]
moi j'ai eu vraiment le même bateau qui
a coulé en fleurs la solitude et coulis
ils sont fous ces élèves que j'ai
longtemps à voir avec une charmante lui
revient toujours sur les bateaux courts
mais dave remonte à
et m
sonova les tamalous
valet
ce qui plaît
oh
et cholet et d'autant de buts prises
tant qu'ils peuvent
gens qui venaient
kohat
avec ce chanteur à valenciennes 2 à la
nôtre à noter à la vie saoudi commandé
au brésil mais bon la rhein comme on dit
on n'a plus un adepte de viviez langues
du monde
peut-être les premiers langues du monde
peut-être si le peuple juif le peuple
élu peut-être leur langue de la premier
league est vrai qu'ils ont ils ont mis
un enfant dès sa naissance dans un
endroit où personne ne parle et les
premiers mots qu'il a 10 km
ça veut dire quoi au l'avait soir la 10e
en et roland n'est pas ce que dit
l'histoire est ce vrai moi je pense que
si on met personne autour du monde qui
se confie pas le rap a d'ailleurs pas
qu'il dira pas un mot
six personnes c'est trop philosophique
au ça fait loin
[Musique]
oui
benneteau
[Musique]
enfin
florence j'ai lu ton bouquin d'ide en
sait quelque chose
ouais c'est pas en mettant des cas des
trucs comme ça pour voir
j'ai pas par rapport à ta famille non
pas du tout mes parents aiment beaucoup
ah bon ouais on se crée la vie tu vas
avec le livre seront pas étonnés
la page page tu peux m'en lire une page
là ok je me trompe pas voilà
prends moi dit il dans un souffle à 10
mètres de là le titre passe d'un cul à
l'autre ainsi jp déboutonne mon pantalon
sa main plonge vers mon sexe se tremper
il joue quelques instants avec tous ses
désirs qui lui coule entre les doigts on
humecte le cul et cartes mes fesses
[Musique]
avant tours je suis plaqué contre une
paroi de ciment qui a des relents
d'urines le visage vissé au béton et
à fond cette fois ci j'ai juste
un frémissement
quand le bourrelet du gland a passé la
ligne
ma chère c'est elle si vite habitué je
ferme les yeux
j'ai envie de le sentir jouir tout de
suite mes envies aussi d'être labouré
longtemps il y ajoute un nouveau est
très proche
hayman elle a fait ça continue c'est
plus entretenues
puis on se le fait à deux et la voix de
jp qui au même instant soir deux mois ce
petit pourquoi pas tient la place
et chaude ça m'apaise sur manu qui me
maintient épinglé à la paroisse
doucement mais doucement
prends ton temps et mènent capote il ya
un flottement des mains puissantes
s'agrippe mes hanches à nouveau cette
vision extérieure à moi même je vois
comme si j'étais à trois mètres de là
mes fesses très blanche
seule lueur dans la nuit glauque de ce
garage et le dos d'un type que je ne
connais pas vers lequel on ne m'a même
pas laissé me retourne et je sens la
petite membrane caoutchouteuse du
réservoir s'appuyer contre mes fesses et
ils s'enfoncent good gracious
l'impression d'être de nouveau pucelle
pas seulement l'appréhension qui me
contracte cela existe donc des membres
pareil il remonte interminablement en
moi et me plaque contre le pilier comme
pour jouir le comme pour fuir le g
monstrueux qui me force à me défonce on
continue dérision ou penser à jal est le
type me donne un coup de poing violent
dans les reins et m'oblige à me cambrai
me donner davantage dans le mouvement
convulsif qui suit il s'enfonce tout
entier les poils de son pubis vienne
raclée ma peau je crie je hurle même la
base de sa queue est si grosse que j'ai
l'impression que mon anus explose je
crie et je sanglote
je commence à aller et venir lentement
d'abord puis de plus en plus fort plus
vite ramenant mélange vers lui à chaque
fois qu'il s'enfonce encore je crie à
chaque fois et puis lubrification de la
capote ou non il coulisse en mois de
plus en plus vite sans peine
j'ai un plaisir étrange comme si je
chier à l'envers quand il est au fond de
moi je marque août pour m'offrir plus à
fond les pensées se bousculent je
comprend bien pourquoi et jp a exigé
qu'il enfile une capote
mais je me désole de savoir que je ne
sentirais pas son me brûler les
entrailles juste un commentaire qui ne
met pas destinée bordaises bordel qu'est
ce qu'ils étaient trois c'est bon
puis tout se passe très vite il passe
une main devant pour me branler sans
doute tâtonne dans le vide
soudain il arrête sa queue à mi chemin
il s'arrache à mes fesses et je crie de
nouveau douleur et désespoir
c'est une de nanars il se tourne
vers jp votre fair m je me retourne
admis le type est un nul être de 25 27
ans il écume de rage dans l'ombre je le
vois des bandes et à vue d'oeil
même ainsi ça que lui arrive à mi cuisse
jp se penche vers moi et me remontent
mon jean
allez viens je me rends boutonne il me
prend la main le noir convulsé lance son
point l'instant d'après il est à terre
saignant vilainement de la bouche
jp se penche le prend par ces méchas
frau lui aplati la gueule trois ou
quatre fois contre le pilier de béton
bruit d'os et de dents éclaté le type
est tout mou maintenant
quand tu dis ça c'est incroyable parce
que on dirait pas du tout public fait
quoi c'est un compliment
lycéens comme si c'était arrivé à
khartoum
oui
l'écriture c'est
la distanciation ouais mais peut-être
que maintenant c'est arrivé à quelqu'un
d'autre pour être échangé depuis
l'époque où tu vivais ça mais on renaît
seront menées en outre comment ça
commence et j'espère en ouvrant la porte
d'une faculté
ouais c'était à la fin la faculté il ya
des profs ouais on adore cette prof donc
s'efforce de les choisir
alors des fois c'est des questions
d'emploi du temps mais des fois on
s'arrange pour les retrouver et donc
c'est improbable que tu as comment ça
s'est passé entre vous j'ai essayé qu'il
me trouve on n'est pas complètement
conscient les plus conscients quand on
écrit et voilà nous l'apporté on est
devant lui s'est aperçu tout de suite
que tu allais mais ça c'est ça ouais
paraît que c'est écrit là
ah bon demain qui voit sa n'ont pas tous
les mecs c'est dommage
bon s'épuiserait beaucoup ok et derek
qui découvre quand il voit une fille
découvre tout de suite qu'elle va aimer
pas qu'elle va aimer ça ouais en tout
cas il y en a un qui l'a vu
à qui on l'a donné à voir il ya déjà
déjà une intuition l'intuition féminine
est ou non et
c'est étrange parce qu'on on dit souvent
qu'on rencontre des gens et qu'on lit
tout dès la première rencontre
et en fait c'est pas qu'on lit tous et
qu'on choisit des gens à qui on donne
tout à lire et on s'aide avance qu'ils
sauront peut-être le lire après nous
amène nathalie ça s'est passé comment la
première fois c'était tout de suite très
feutré à l'extrême
ah bah tout de suite on comprend que on
amener vers autre chose au delà de soi
même
il a une emprise sur toi tout de suite
quoi ouais
ouais on choisit
choisi de livrer quelque chose de soi
même sur lequel il va d enfin on va
tirer le maximum était amené ou la
première fois l'année chez moi ouais
qu'est ce qui t'a fait
il m'a il a ouvert une porte qui était
jamais ouverte
il ya une chanson qui est
si des états unis qui dit tu peut cogner
mais tu peux pas rentrer je peut cogner
mais tu peux pas rentrer chez la porte
en avant qui ferme et puis après le
deuxième couple s est tu peut cogner
mais tu peux pas rentrer je pourtant
derrière qui est toujours fermé voilà
c'est déjà ça va cogner partout voilà
des buts attaché au radiateur
non
et des radiateurs électriques non non
c'est un peu difficile ouais même les
cheveux et crame non pas le radiateur ça
va être un petit peu surfait on
s'attache tout seul en fait on s'attache
sur radio fait un nom s'attache tout
cela soit c'est peut-être ça qu'on
apprend moi c'est un des trucs les plus
hard que j'ai jamais eu ben ça se
passait les endroits un peu comme ça bon
un peu comme ça un peu plus peuplé ouais
on a oublié les figurants c'est bien
d'ailleurs
mais ici la vue est vraiment belle il
donner en pâture à des mecs quoi
ouais mais c'est moi quand on me voit
comme ça on va dire tellement bcbg
oui on a des masques multiples ouais
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
écoutons simonet sa l'apec les diamants
on est mondiaux n'est qu'il est chez
piano piano
ennjimi forte et ça me plaisait chine
j'ai dû stopper
[Musique]
ça
c'est là
[Musique]
m
avant à six mois
[Musique]
hommen
c'est lui
ils vont encore sur l'a4 temps en temps
on est très loin temps ouais là plus
besoin ouais mais en bon mais avec le
reste est lui tu crois qu'aujourd'hui
vit la même chose avec d'autres filles
ou que ça reste pour lui une expérience
ça serait dommage pour lui ouais
non il ya une forme de respect si on
fait les choses avec les gens sur le
mais on est dans le feuilleton
ouais
tu peux
je suis pas mieux cette page je trouvais
je conviens
mais bien sûr ça va
je ne ferai pas le détail il m'a laissé
attaché toute la journée
il ne me d'été chacune fois sur moder
une à faire pipi et me rattache à aussi
fort il photographia sans relâche en
plan très serré qui ne me permettait pas
d'identifier qui que ce soit juste mes
fesses
entre ma bouche et le ventre les hanches
et là que des types qui me pénétrer il
avait dû leur fixer un certain quant au
col une fois installé il faisait jacques
hull est toujours là où il s'était
enfoncé
je veux ce jour là plus de sperme
congelé
avait jamais avalé je fus beaucoup
cela aussi faisait peut-être
partie du rite quelques-uns plus rare
préférèrent mon ventre assez nombreux
pour temps pour que je me sens très vite
les filets de
et sur les plus
qui était-il j'ai peur de montrer les
photos de jour
plus tard
de beaux tirages brillant en 13 18 et
les couleurs n'était france d'une
pellicule à grain fin
au total 23 type n'avait pénétré ce jour
là certains ont du ventre des poils vous
clés sur des bedaines confortable
ou les muscles saillants
peu de blanc
à tous les poils gris
lors qu'elles sont de toutes les formes
et de tous les calibres il y en a quatre
qui sont accrochés à des ventres très
plat et imberbe sans doute des
adolescents qui ont d'ailleurs tous
choisis ma bouche
des adolescents qui ont d'ailleurs
toujours sur la bouche
frais comme des bananes
comme des stars
mince et grenu comme des saucisses
d'auvergne courte et épaisse gros fruits
purpura gilson dutronc dans les films ou
les magazines porno on ne voit jamais
qu'un modèle de beat un calibre presque
immuable
au casting un peu comme les seins
hypertrophié hyper réaliste des stars
féminines du hard barbie miracle de
l'art chirurgie plastique
dès que de toutes les couleurs aussi des
hommes à la peau très mat dont le gland
violacé vient me tutoyer les lèvres un
asiatique au poids la peine vous plaît 3
noir très noir tous train manque
quelques photos ont été prises aussi
alors qu'il venait juste de se retirer
entre deux visites
gros plan sur mon visage vite trempé de
larmes
tous ces sont allés fort et loin
dans ma bouche gros plan sur montcuq
l'anus ou vera le temps comme
bush de carpes incroyablement dilater le
sexe bail comme un coquillage renonçant
à garder ses perles des larmes de
durci par les clichés soins temps de
trouver tous
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle s'habille comme lui d'un pantalon
d'un blouson quand on les rencontre la
nuit on dirait deux garçons leurs
visages paré masqué
comment deviner il le sait mais il joue
des jeux dont je veux c'est là qu'ils
trouvent leur joie
c'est le temps et n'importe quoi
âge tendre et tête de bois
il ne se sent jamais dit plus petits
mots d'amour
il se balade dans la vie en copain de
toujours
ils pensent que c'est démodé de se
l'avouer il le sait mais ils ont des
jeux
deux gamins mais leur coeur est déjà
loin si le temps des n'importe quoi
âge tendre et tête de bois
ils vont tous les jours tous les jours
cinéma quand ils sortent du ciné du prel
un coca cola et comme d habitude ils
écoutent la machine qui paie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
pas
/
quand lula
[Musique]
il
m
[Musique]
homo
[Applaudissements]
elle est belle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
soit je faisais une petite sieste là
j'étais en train de lire un texte alors
j'ai quand même l'intention de vous lire
sérieusement alors fais tout moi je vais
faire ça
enfin un virus est un programme capable
de modifier d'autres programmes en iroko
pian tous partie de son propre programme
un tel programme et auteur aux
producteurs il est également la plupart
des cas auto modifiant cette propriété
et cette propriété inhabituel de
taureaux production des programmes de
virus et est grave
dangereuse et est nuisible car bien
entendu
rares sont les programmes de virus qui
ceux qui se contentent de cet âge de
reproduction
il possède en plus dans la plupart des
cas une tâche de destruction pouvant
aller du quart ac kaka du caractère face
alors à la modification au à la
destruction des informations contenues
dans les mémoires de masse du disque est
discuté à la détérioration de layton
d'habiller bienbienbien cocotte
critiques à l'adresse des définitions
david à virus soit à un programme
capable de tout autre programme la la la
la tâche de delta studio net de tenay
tonka plus courants excédant la suite de
cet ouvrage qu'avril cas virus passe at
il une routine de deux des stups
d'expulsion ne nous a pas trop
au terme des stocks sont à associer
toutes routes est destiné à faire
apparaître des mavs à congo dans
l'exécution dans le pro gbagbo au sens
où on l'entend à une tâche de tout même
si le programme d'anti contaminé
continue de le faire alors est-ce qu'un
programme est victime un bon match fut
par l'action de david ont dit qu'is
québec qui qui qui qui dès qu'il est
infecté ou cocon concorde un cadeau
pourrait ainsi enfin vava possédait les
mêmes conditions avec ce style de vie
rustique la culture propres effectifs à
dire le coucou coucou dans l'émission
serait ce la pâte
une façon pour affection que vient le
début 2009 lorsque des miliciens de vote
le linebacker des îlots récolte pour
nous lancer de tongs reste on fait une
loi cet automne pour une sortie ils ne
sont pas faits que je sais c'est pas mal
mais j'essaie faisait faillite
the sun the cell the fall mbaye ndoye
les jetons devant la justice
ils ne jouent pas le jeu c'est très bien
mais je sais pas nous voir la vache
il nous faudrait une loi
le monde ne peut pas ne pas braquer sur
lui mais il ne manque pas un vain le web
[Musique]
touche pas
malgré cette faille que c'était bon
il relève t il
à bazet legnano loin que chaque femme
tous parents je devrais
un chat ça vaille que ce noir
quelle maman et leurs rêves
mauvais calcul mais cette fois le même
elmer lach sites bannis qu'elle se
démarre
tucson
je suis marié j'ai deux rails
non
le monde est vaste et démarrer le mois
[Musique]
tu chantes pas décevoir
le choix du nom breux
decelles
helman bac
non
et
t2i nos latitudes abonnez vous y mettez
un peu de bleu